en la cumbre del clima con 26 más de 100
líderes se comprometieron a reducir sus
emisiones de metano 30 por ciento para
el 2030 y se discutió la financiación de
economías más verdes desde los países
desarrollados que incumplieron para el
2020 y ajustaron el plazo del 2023 en el
encuentro pese a la incapacidad para
alcanzar las metas climáticas del 2030
en virginia de eeuu avanza el conteo de
la elección de gobernador que marcará
tendencia en las legislativas de medio
término el próximo año el republicano
glenn young kim lleva ventaja en el
estado tradicionalmente demócrata y en
nueva york que cerró la votación de
alcalde un afroamericano podría ser el
segundo en la historia de la ciudad en
ocupar el cargo
y hoy 2 de noviembre se conmemora el día
internacional contra la impunidad de los
crímenes contra periodistas en su
informe anual la unesco recordó al menos
400 asesinatos de reporteros en todo el
mundo en los últimos cinco años y alertó
que la tasa de impunidad ronda del 87
por ciento tenemos análisis
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y regreso con las noticias de
france 24 iniciamos el informativo con
la actualización en la tercera jornada
de la cumbre del clima kobe 26 este
martes más líderes mundiales hicieron
nuevos compromisos la reducción de
emisiones de metano y la financiación de
economías más verdes por parte de los
países más desarrollados fueron puntos
de mayor discusión y se sumaron a la
promesa de este lunes de frenar la
deforestación sin embargo no todas las
naciones se comprometieron en favor
desde el medio ambiente para el 2030
informa juan pabló él lucumí
llegan más promesas a favor del medio
ambiente por parte de los líderes
mundiales en el marco de la cop 26 un
centenar de países se suma a eeuu y la
unión europea para reducir hasta el 2030
un 30 por ciento de la producción del
gas metano uno de los principales
responsables del calentamiento global
sin embargo australia ha rechazado la
propuesta y los grandes emisores de
metano rusia china e india no han
firmado
mismas todavía quedan dos semanas de
negociación detallada debemos cuidarnos
de las falsas esperanzas y no pensar de
ninguna manera que el trabajo está hecho
porque no lo está todavía queda un largo
camino por recorrer pero dicho esto soy
cautelosamente optimista
i'm just be ops mystic limitar el
calentamiento global a 1,5 grados
centígrados ha sido un reto aceptado por
países como colombia china e india
aunque no todos aceptaron cumplirlo para
el plazo fijado el año 2030 países como
brasil república democrática del congo e
indonesia que en conjunto representan el
85 por ciento de bosques del mundo
comprometido a detener y revertir la
deforestación para el final de la década
una meta respaldada por 19 mil millones
de dólares en fondos públicos y privados
reconocemos que nuestra tecnología
actual por sí sola no nos llevará a
donde debemos estar por lo que también
debe ser una década decisiva para la
innovación el desarrollo y la
comercialización de nuevas tecnologías
para el 2030 actuar en ferrari para
cumplir el objetivo de financiación de
los países ricos hacia aquellos en
desarrollo japón se comprometió este
martes a aportar con 10 mil millones de
dólares en 5 años y aunque las promesas
económicas son muchas los 100 mil
millones de dólares anuales fijados para
el año 2020 han fracasado la nueva meta
económica se cumplirá con miras al 2023
según informó el presidente de la cumbre
cambio de tema hay noticias de eeuu hoy
ya se conocen algunos resultados
iniciales de las elecciones de hoy en el
estado de virginia con cerca del 60 por
ciento escrutado el republicano glenn
edición king acumula ventaja por encima
del demócrata terry mcauliffe una
posible derrota de los demócratas en
virginia estado donde el mandatario job
aiden ganó por 10 puntos sobre el
entonces de presidente republicano
donald trump el año pasado haría sonar
las alarmas para los liberales de cara a
las legislativas de medio término el
próximo año el virtual ganador es john
quien le prometió dar a los padres más
control sobre cómo las escuelas públicas
manejan los protocolos de raza género y
kobe 19 mientras mcauliffe aseguró que
protegería el acceso al aborto y a los
derechos del voto
también nueva yersey elige gobernador y
entretanto decenas de las principales
ciudades de eeuu o votaron ya por
alcaldes entre los comicios hay uno
clave en la ciudad de nueva york que es
donde se espera que el demócrata ex
capitán de policía eric adams se
convierta en el segundo alcalde
afrodescendiente de la ciudad pero se
enfrenta al republicano curtis sliwa que
dirige la patrulla civil o dirigió la
patrulla civil de los ángeles guardianes
y no se descarta una sorpresa los
detalles los tiene nuestra corresponsal
ámame en sala
ha sido una jornada de votación muy
tranquila con poca afluencia en los
centros de votación muchos habían
ejercido el derecho de voto anticipado
para evitar las aglomeraciones y son dos
contrincantes los que pelean por la
alcaldía de la ciudad más grande de eeuu
en el lado demócrata eric adams de 61
años es agente de policía y si gana esta
noche se convertirá en el segundo
afroamericano en la historia de la
ciudad de nueva york en convertirse en
alcalde a eric adams ha estado en contra
del de font de polis es decir de
financiar a la policía ha sido un gran
defensor de los agentes y en el otro
lado tenemos al republicano cartes silva
que lo hemos visto esta mañana también
hacia las 10 de la mañana ha ejercido su
derecho al voto acompañado de su gato un
personaje muy mediático en esta ciudad
porque formó esa patrulla urbana
desarmada en los años 70 cuando la
ciudad de nueva york había muchísimo
crimen estos son los dos contrincantes
desde luego quien gane esta noche que es
muy probable como decía que sea el
demócrata tiene un panorama nada fácil
va a heredar una ciudad que no solamente
se enfrenta a la pandemia al ascenso de
la variante delta también a un aumento
en el índice de criminalidad y a ese
cambio esas reformas dentro de la
policía que hasta ahora parece que nadie
se ha atrevido a hacer un panorama nada
fácil para iniciar el nuevo mandato en
la alcaldía hoy es el día internacional
contra la impunidad de los crímenes
contra periodistas la unesco emitió su
reporte anuales sobre la violencia
contra la prensa y explicó que en los
últimos cinco años se registraron 400
asesinatos de reporteros o camarógrafos
y fotógrafos en todo el mundo con una
tasa de impunidad del 87 por ciento
además la ong reporteros sin fronteras
dijo que en lo que va del 2021 35 fueron
asesinados y 348 están encarcelados
france24 recuerda el caso de jean fold y
el primer reportero estadounidense que
falleció a manos del autodenominado
estado islámico
hace siete años sin fold y se convirtió
en el primer periodista estadounidense
en ser ejecutado por el grupo estado
islámico su decapitación filmada y su
vida en línea conmocionó al mundo para
la madre de folk y jim murió por los
valores que apreciaba
quién murió por lo que pensó que era la
verdad por lo que sintió que era
importante sintió que era un trabajo que
debía hacerse estaba soltero sentía que
podía hacerlo le encantó le encantó
escuchar lo que estaba pasando y luego
escribir la historia capturando las
imágenes para traer de vuelta al mundo
michaels
tres semanas después de la muerte de jim
ryan foley creó una fundación pidiendo
al gobierno de eeuu que hiciera más para
liberar a los rehenes reporteros o no
cada vez es más peligroso ser periodista
ya sea en este país o en todo el mundo y
creo que esto se debe principalmente a
que hay mucha desinformación ahora que
hace más difícil que la verdad salga a
la luz
a menos que se responsabiliza a las
personas que atacan matan y torturan a
los periodistas con suerte
la isla al arian ha convertido en una
prioridad proteger a sus reporteros
después de 20 años de informar en
entornos hostiles ahora es ella quien
envía a los periodistas a los sitios de
peligro con protocolos de seguridad que
tratamos de averiguar todo lo posible
sobre el sitio al que vamos en lugar de
simplemente lanzarnos en paracaídas y no
darnos cuenta atacados encarcelados o
asesinados la violencia en contra de los
periodistas ha aumentado en todo el
mundo en los últimos 30 años más de 1400
han sido asesinados y los perpetradores
rara vez comparecen ante la justicia
para el análisis del tema está con
nosotros balbina flores representante de
la organización reporteros sin fronteras
en mexico balbina gracias a ustedes y
vamos precisamente a hablar de la región
méxico es uno de los países de mayor
riesgo para ejercer el periodismo quien
silenciar a la prensa y por qué
bueno quien silencia la prensa y porque
en méxico
específicamente quienes silencian a la
prensa en más del 60% son funcionarios
públicos después le sigue el crimen
organizado y siguen también líderes
sociales entonces esa es la cifra porque
porque los periodistas se han atrevido a
denunciar la corrupción las violaciones
graves a derechos humanos en los
rincones últimos del país donde donde no
llega nadie más que los periodistas este
esto es algo que hemos observado a lo
largo de todos estos años y asimismo la
impunidad es una característica de los
crímenes que se registran contra
periodistas y le pregunto existe
voluntad política para esclarecer estos
casos
bueno hasta este momento no lo hemos
visto esta voluntad que se se concrete
en acciones auto específicas por parte
del gobierno y eso es lo que queda
pendiente este gobierno todavía tiene la
oportunidad del gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador de demostrar en los
años que le quedan los últimos tres años
de su gobierno que hay voluntad para
hacer retroceder la inmunidad en los
asesinatos de periodistas y en las
desaparecidos bueno y entre tanto
américa latina es además la región del
mundo más peligroso para ejercer
periodismo porque en su opinión
bueno américa latina' hace rato que está
registrando altos índices de asesinatos
de periodistas
hay una situación que se ha venido
complicando que es que en muchos países
las democracias han ido retrocediendo y
se han ido convirtiendo en dictaduras
terribles como es el caso de nicaragua
como es el caso de venezuela que son
países donde la libertad de expresión
cada vez está más deteriorada
y para finalizar también quiero
preguntarle qué garantías son las que
necesitan el ejercicio periodístico y
que reclama reporteros sin fronteras
para que los reporteros puedan ejercer
su labor libremente y no convertirse en
víctimas de la violencia y de los
conflictos que cubren
bueno en primer lugar lo que reportero
sin fronteras está exigiendo este 2 de
noviembre es poner fin a los crímenes en
contra de periodistas en américa latina'
fin a la impunidad
si esto fuera posible lo que los
periodistas necesitan es libertad para
hacer su trabajo diario
pues le agradezco mucho y continuamos
con más noticias en france 24 en nigeria
un grupo de hombres armados secuestró en
la universidad de abuya a cuatro
miembros del personal y a sus hijos un
niño y una niña pandillas de hombres
armados cometieron desde fines del año
pasado una serie de secuestros en
escuelas y propiciaron ataques en aldeas
principalmente en el noroeste del país a
cambio de rescates aunque episodios de
este tipo se han presentado a las
afueras de abuya las autoridades
consideran que los asaltos a
universidades son raros
en las zonas y tan pronto como lo
conseguimos hemos movilizado el ejército
la policía a todos en realidad estábamos
aquí para ese momento hemos iniciado la
persecución y eso continúa hasta ahora
antes
no la verdad es que este es uno de los
incidentes más devastadores se está
convirtiendo en un asunto cotidiano en
este país y es muy triste que esta gran
universidad haya sido atacada de esta
manera
si
bien en otras noticias un tren de carga
en el sur de chile fue descarrilado y
algunas de sus unidades quemadas por
asaltantes esto en medio de tensiones
entre el gobierno y el grupo indígena
mapuche que exige la devolución de
tierras ancestrales los vagones
transportaban celulosa para la
fabricación de papel por la zona que se
encuentra en estado de emergencia debido
al conflicto el delegado presidencial de
víctor manuel iii calificó los hechos de
terrorismo y agregó que hasta el momento
nadie se había atribuido la
responsabilidad del atentado que provocó
la suspensión del servicio de trenes
desde la localidad de victoria y temuco
hasta la capital regional de la
araucanía hogar de los mapuches se
pronunció también el presidente
sebastián piñera
estamos plenamente conscientes
preocupados y ocupados
por la grave alteración del orden
público la seria amenaza a la seguridad
ciudadana y las graves consecuencias
para la ciudadanía que generan los
violentos atentados que cometen estas
bandas de crimen organizado
ligadas al narcotráfico al terrorismo y
al robo de madera conocemos y
solidarizamos con el dolor y la angustia
que estos graves y violentos atentados
provocan en las víctimas mapuches y no
mapuches y un abogado de la cantante
britney spears pidió interrogar a su
padre bajo juramento sobre cómo gastó el
dinero del artista durante 13 años que
supervisó su tutela quedó consignado en
documentos legales presentados ante una
audiencia judicial de clave que se
realizará la próxima semana el abogado
matthew rosengard set también quiere que
jamie spears envíe respuestas escritas y
documentos sobre afirmaciones de que una
empresa de seguridad de monitoreo spears
la tutela fue aprobada en 2008 después
de que ella sufre colapso de salud
mental un juez suspendió a jamie spears
como tutor a finales de septiembre
hasta aquí el informativo ya volvemos
con más en francés 24
[Música]